let's return to our top story and the
list of conservative mps to withdraw
their confidence in boris johnson is
growing a total of 13 by our reckoning
have so far called on the prime minister
to resign
joining us now the former defense
minister chair of the defense select
committee tobias ellwood mr elwood great
to see you this morning um i wonder if
we can start by just asking your view
on the parliamentary
chicanery that we saw yesterday a u-turn
denied as a u-turn by conor burns on the
programme this morning but but a u-turn
it clearly looks
you know it was i think the chief webb
did well to contain yesterday's damage
by pulling
uh the government uh uh amendment uh
moving to a one-line whip
but the bigger picture here is that
all mps are in deeply troubled by uh
what is the party is now going through
and what to do
next given the huge credit you must give
to boris johnson in bringing the party
you know so far but
we we must stop drinking that kool-aid
that's encouraging us i think this is
all going to disappear that we can all
move on we we can't use ukraine as a fig
leaf to dodge those difficult questions
uh the issue of uh party gate continues
to distract from both domestic
and international uh issues and it's
just one going away and we're going to
see it i'm afraid a steady trickle of
letters resignations as that's now
starting to happen i predicted that um
you know you listen carefully to the i'm
afraid the silence of support and it's
clear that more and more mps
are privately believed that it's the
time that the leadership batman has
actually passed on
but but but in terms of of where this
story might go next is that is there any
alternative in your mind to to that
which many people that which many people
assume will happen boris johnson will
cling on to power we'll hold on to the
keys to number 10 for as long as
possible those letters will continue to
trickle in
and the conservatives will get an
absolute drubbing in the polls
no that as i say there's a also
recognition that every mp now
it it's up to us to to take ownership of
this because there is that uh i'm afraid
the absence of discipline the focus of
leadership in number 10 during that
lockdown period has led to a huge breach
of trust with the british people and is
causing such long-term damage to the
party's brand and that's proving
difficult to repair can it be repaired
in time for the next general election so
it's beholden upon all conservative mps
then to take matters into their own
hands and i think as i say i think this
is where things will go particularly as
we have more bad news to follow
um steve baker uh said yesterday the gig
is up that the prime minister's
contrition lasted as long as it took to
to get out of the headmaster study roger
gale uh commented on the prime
minister's performance in front of the
22 on tuesday as a pantomime um were you
at that meeting how would you have
characterized what the prime minister
said and did
well i mean i agree with steve baker
sadly you know there was such a change
in attitude between what we saw uh in
the house of commons in the chamber to
then the sense of relief almost by the
prime minister and thinking that he's
now able to move on uh and uh can put
this all all behind him and that just
isn't the the attitude that uh uh is
going to go down well uh with the the
british people and that's what counts
there's many reports many reviews taking
place that you know studies will now
happen uh to do with the privileges
committee and so forth
ultimately it's whether or not we can
win the next general election with uh
boris johnson in charge and if we
believe that we can't do that then yes
we have to go through that process as
you did with margaret thatcher john
major as has happened in other parts
as well to say it's time to refresh it's
time to regroup under another leader and
i stress you cannot use uh ukraine as
some form of fig leave to say no we
can't go down this difficult road
to what extent is the prime minister
still prime minister because of the
support of his cabinet colleagues if
someone significantly senior within the
cabinet pop their head above the panna
pits before now
there's a very real possibility that he
would no longer be prime minister
yes i mean you talk of a number of
avenues if you like that could be
pursued that could facilitate very fast
change in what's happening i suspect
it's going to be the uh accumulation of
letters into the 1922 ultimately with
more fixed penalty notices to come the
sugray report of course it'll be the
local elections maybe that for for many
of my colleagues who would eventually
say i've had i've had enough and
i've actually
pushed this to the prime minister a
couple of weeks ago to say this is
crisis management is required here
put a timetable together offer it to
members of parliament so we can actually
you know draw a line on the discussions
about this every day after the local
elections if they don't go well
have that vote of confidence in yourself
call it yourself and the party then
decides one way or another whether we
stay with the prime minister committed
and we move forward until the general
election likely to take place uh next uh
september or we absolutely then go down
that occasional difficult road that the
party does go down in selecting a new
leader
you've mentioned the way in which um the
government has used the situation in
ukraine as as part of the defense of the
prime minister a couple of times now i'm
just wondering as someone who has served
as someone who has seen combat are you
not
livid
at the use of the sacrifice of the
bravery of people who are fighting any
war as a political defense for this
prime minister does that not infuriate
you
well in fairness the prime minister
hasn't gone down this road itself it's
been some of his supporters that says it
would be wrong to do this at this moment
i may make it very very clear that the
whitehall rolls-royce machinery uh you
know the mod capability in offering
options risk assessments uh
recommendations for any prime minister
is the best in the world our policy in
ukraine began back in 2014
under a very different prime minister
who started to arm and train uh the
ukrainian forces that's been upgraded
today we're moving even further than
that and there isn't going to be a lull
around the corner where ukraine's
activities will die down for us to then
look at domestic fares the security in
europe is about to decay over the next
decade
we need to grasp this we cannot use the
ukraine uh you know as a fig leaf indeed
if there was a leadership election i
could see candidates falling over
themselves to actually increase their
support we're still absent to the
strategy you know what does all this
weapon systems that we're giving to
ukraine where does it lead to are we
content with seeing part of don bass
remain in russian's hands or are we
going to go back to 2000 pre-2014
borders and push russia out which is
where i would like to go otherwise putin
will simply do all this again because
he'll survive and then he'll attack
another country in a couple of years
time big questions that have been
answered about where we go with ukraine
and russian strategy
to myself good to have you on the
programme this morning thanks for being
with us
thank you